hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen zum ersten videos meiner
neuen wohnung ich werde am ende noch ein
bisschen was über die wohnung und den
umzug und solar bahn aber wir fangen
jetzt erst mal mit dem spiel denn wir
spielen heute das spiel the game
irgendwie kann man das dann lesen
sorry falls der sound noch ein bisschen
scheiße ist aber dass halt hier alles
noch ein bisschen aber dazu werde ich
später noch mehr erzählen jedenfalls
klicken wir einfach mal auf play
das gehalt play the game shows wie level
bla bla bla bla bla wir klicken 1 x days
of the game
wir können hier von a nach b laufen und
es passiert wir haben uns selbst getötet
ich bin gerade albert einstein und
irgendwie weiß ich gerade nicht ganz
genau was ich machen soll
es ist nicht wahr da ist schon wieder
einfach passiert irgendwas wenn ich hier
was muss ich denn machen bei diesem
spiel kann ich mich irgendwie jetzt hier
und ist ins plus
ich glaube dieses spiel stellt einfach
verschiedene politische ansichten da was
geht man
ich mache es für ein vernünftiges spiel
stattdessen ist es dahin trotz das
schwachsinn censorship begann
es ist einfach weiß unzensiert shooting
neues interface endlich konnten wir das
machen wir sollen anwälten ins gesicht
schießen einfach klar natürlich sterben
wir domestic sparring also diese leute
ausspionieren und was alles sieht und
rechts ist mit rekorde
das heißt wenn ich sterbe können wir uns
noch mal genau anschauen wie ich
gestorben bin
das bin ich alkoholismus ok alkoholismus
in ein spiel klingt mit rang basterd
stars never ending song breit wenn man
englisch nicht sicher was steht da denn
jetzt schon wieder muss ich wieder
sterben oder was haltet ihr dad ließ
tommy press and space in abo dance for
you steht trotzdem das war das spiel
ich hätte wirklich mehr erwartet
es tut mir leid falls eventuell der ein
oder andere der alte die tags für das
spiel sind einfach suicide satire
politics and portal history 2011 und
deshalb drei millionen views ich hoffe
dass das ganze euch gefallen hat
mir ehrlich gesagt nicht natürlich es
war ein bisschen sozial und
gesellschaftskritisch aber ich denke
jetzt nicht dass es den großteil von
euch angesprochen hat das gehalt das
wäre so was ähnliches wie diese sticker
die bei euch einmal super cool an kam
jedenfalls nutze ich jetzt einfach mal
die zeit um noch ein bisschen über den
umzug und veränderungen zu reden das
heißt wenn ich euch nicht wichtig bin
könnt ihr gerne einfach ich würde mich
freuen wenn ihr dran bleibt ich bin
umgezogen und zwar als das hier meine
neue wohnung beziehen das ist nur ein
neues aufnahme zimmer hier im
hintergrund seht ihr meinen
kleiderschrank aber da möchte ich keinen
allzu großen einblick craften gewähren
kommt hier werdet ihr mich demnächst
öfter sehen es kann allerdings sein dass
in den nächsten fünf sechs videos
irgendwie noch ein anderer hintergrund
ist oder der am immer ab und zu wechselt
weil ich halt bisschen vorproduziert
dabei sich in berlin und in london bin
ich wollte nur sagen dass hier auf jeden
fall noch ein teppich reinkommt ich
wollte eventuell eine matte hier hinter
hecken oder einem greenscreen also in
amerika und england bei den letzteren
ist es ja schon standard das team green
screen hinter sich haben in deutschland
jetzt noch nicht so deswegen habe ich
halt gedacht weil sie auch ein bisschen
schall rausnimmt denn so einen green
screen sondern mattes ding hinter einem
steht hat sich das überlegt zu machen
hier kommen noch bilder hin und dann
kommt doch immer meine set up tour ich
habe hier oben auch ein riesiges fenster
das ganze ist deswegen ist das licht
ganz gut vielmehr möchte ich eigentlich
gar nicht sagen ich bin umgezogen und
deswegen anderer hintergrund wenn euch
sonst das video gefallen hat würde ich
mich bei den bewertungen freuen schreibt
mir doch mal einfach andere spielen
kommentare beginn wurde mir so viele
kommentare stehen aber selbst crêpes und
dann sehen wir uns mal anders wieder